We're going to keep coming back to this equation as we learn new skills to see
if we can solve it. But for now let's start by solving a number puzzle. For
number puzzles, we're going to find 2 numbers that multiply to give us the top
number and that add to give the bottom number. So for this one I want to find
factors of 20 that sum to 9. We can think about it in our heads or make a list
of the factor pairs. This is usually more helpful. We start with 1 since 1
divides into any number. 1 times 20 is 20. So this is definitely a factor pair.
2 times 10 is 20, that's another one and 4 times is 20. So this is our third
factor pair. I don't need to continue writing any more factor pairs because well
I've repeated one of them already. Ten and two would end up being repeated as
would 20 and one if I continued listing factor pairs so if I'm going in order I
can just stop when I have a repeat. I look at my list and I see which one of the
pairs adds up to nine, that must be this one. So four and five would be the
answer to this number puzzle.